the david pakman show at david
pakman.com this is a fantastic and
stunning story and it relates to the now
I guess I'll say six or more allegations
of sexual assault against the Alabama
Republican Senate candidate Roy Moore
when there are sexual assault
allegations generally you always have
this faction that likes to say the
allegations are made up we can't believe
the allegations but there are also some
who are more specific and they say it's
not that the women aren't credible as a
general thing it's that anyone who wants
to hurt a politician can go to the media
and say so-and-so assaulted me just to
get stories written about them to hurt
them politically and the argument is
from some particularly on the right that
the media whoever the media is are just
so eager to publish this type of story
that they will do it on the say-so of
one alleged victim without actually
trying to fact-check or do background
research and the truth is that when the
Washington Post published the stories of
women who said we were sexually
assaulted by Roy Moore many
right-wingers did exactly this they were
we're very quickly writing it off as oh
it's the Washington Post doing a
political hit piece to hurt Roy Moore in
the election the right-wingers pointing
out Oh
Amazon or Jeff Bezos owns the Washington
Post and he's a big left winger I don't
even know if that's true actually but in
any case saying you can't trust the
reports because the Washington Post is
not really researching this stuff
they're publishing nonsense they've not
done their due diligence to figure out
are these women maybe telling the truth
or are these women just making stuff up
and this is where it gets great okay
remember this guy James O'Keefe he's the
sort of right-wing troll provocateur who
likes to do undercover
according to try to sting different
people and so often his sting attempts
completely backfire he did this at acorn
he did this with Planned Parenthood
there's a very long list of them and
many of them have absolutely horribly
backfired on him he's connected to this
organization Project Veritas and what
Project Veritas and James O'Keefe did
was send a woman to the Washington Post
to lie to straight up lie and say Roy
Moore sexually assaulted me and the idea
was if the Washington Post publishes
this then Project Veritas can come out
and say look this woman went to the
Washington Post made up this story about
Roy Moore and they published it and it
would sort of serve to discredit all of
the previous accusers of Roy Moore so
what did the woman do she got in touch
with the Washington Post she had a
meeting with them and in that meeting
she said I was 15 years old I had a
sexual relationship with Roy Moore where
I got pregnant and ultimately I got an
abortion and again the idea was get
Washington Post to publish this to then
say we tricked them and we can't believe
any of the women what are the Washington
Post a well they investigated the claims
and they started to see them as sort of
suspect they thought maybe this is a
fake story first the Washington Post
noticed that there were some
inconsistencies in the woman's story and
then they went online and they found an
Internet posting from a woman who said
basically I'm moving to New York I've
accepted a job working in the
conservative media movement to combat
the lies and deceit of the liberal
mainstream media I'll be using my skills
as a researcher and fact checker to help
our movement and the Washington Post
research team had reason to believe that
that post was from the woman that met
with them and it's kind of weird if you
say well I'm moving to New York to work
in conservative activism and right after
you moved to New York what you do is
call up the Washington Post and say hey
Roy Moore sexually assaulted me when I
was 15
so the Washington Post goes and
confronts the woman and she insists
listen I'm not working with anyone I'm
just a woman telling my story of sexual
assault well Washington Post was getting
more and more suspicious so they started
a sort of paying attention to where it
was that the woman was going what is it
that she's doing during the day
and they caught her walking into the
office of none other than James o
keeffe's project Veritas so then the
Washington Post says let's confront
James O'Keefe about this woman and here
is what happened when the Washington
Post tried to get James O'Keefe to tell
them hey is this woman working for you
because she came to us and said Roy
Moore sexually assaulted her my question
for you guys well here's a deal
so the other night Wednesday night in
Virginia there's a woman who approached
us this morning it's really cute
you guys are borrowing well here's the
here's the problem someone approached
The Washington Post reporter yeah saying
that she was impregnated by Roy prob was
that truthful or was that a problem the
problem is you're busy so if you'd like
to make an appointment please call our
office for make an appointment okay
thank you if you're not involved you
pretty easily just say no we don't we
don't know who that is we don't know
what you're talking about you don't do
this and then there was a follow up and
James O'Keefe was asked are you working
with Roy Moore in some capacity and he
also didn't answer that so as a result
what does the Washington Post done well
they've published the woman's
off-the-record comments which include
her original contact with The Washington
Post saying she has something but she
needs to keep herself safe and the
entire story just basically completely
fell apart this was a clear sting
operation to make the Washington Post
seem as though they will report any
allegation of sexual assault and the
Washington Post didn't they investigated
and they did the right thing they were
the targets of a sting operation to
discredit Roy Moore's accusers this
vindicates the Washington Post and I can
imagine the people at Project Veritas
sitting around scheming thinking oh this
is just gonna be so brilliant
and then it completely blows up in their
face and the real problem this is what
concerns me is that some people will
misunderstand the story and they'll
misunderstand the headline and they will
think that the stories about Roy Moore
that have previously been published were
all false because when you look at some
of the headlines for the story a woman
approached the Washington Post with
dramatic false tales about Roy Moore if
you just read that and I'm curious Pat
whether you agree with me about this
might you not come away thinking that
all of the stories we've heard so far
are the fake ones when the truth is this
makes those other stories more
believable yeah I mean I think it's one
thing to go out there and try to
discredit the mainstream media sure some
people don't like them to begin with
easy target when you're trying to
discredit previous sexual misconduct
Ledger's that's horrible you are going
and specifically trying to say the
however what I have all five or six gone
through the Washington Post I don't even
know at this point the idea is to cast
doubt upon how truthful the original
accusers are because it was the
Washington Post that made some of those
reports and the truth is we now can
trust the Washington Post more than
maybe we did and we should be skeptical
of every media outlet of course but the
fact that the Washington Post didn't
just rush and say hey here's another one
let's publish this one too they actually
investigated and they said you know what
this was an attempt to sting us and they
they don't do it the way that the right
wing says they do it number one that's
why this didn't work and number two this
is why it's particularly ridiculous for
Trump to write off the New York Times in
the Washington Post as fake news
left-wing bomb throwers Washington
posted the exact right thing here and I
applaud them for it 100%
here's the back story on what's going on
with net neutrality and this latest bit
of news about Comcast is exactly exactly
what I've been predicting for years and
many others we told you yesterday
Donald Trump has selected months ago
Ajit PI to run the FCC he's a former
Verizon lawyer and he is now putting
forth actually a
thing on a full repeal of the net
neutrality regulations that were passed
under President Obama and I spent some
time yesterday on the program telling
you many of the reasons why this is a
veritable disaster and I mentioned that
those opposed to the repeal I'm sorry
those opposed to net neutrality are
mostly big internet and telecom
companies their executives their
lobbyists that the public by and large
to the extent that they understand what
net neutrality is is hugely in favor of
net neutrality now companies like
Comcast and other Internet service
providers have been saying for years
don't worry
consumers just because we could do all
of these really bad things
if net neutrality were repealed we're
not going to do them we have no plan to
do those things so you don't have to
worry and Comcast is one of those right
for years Comcast has been lobbying
against internet service providers being
classified as common carriers for
example that's a key provision of net
neutrality and they've been saying
endlessly we have no plan to create
internet slow lanes and fast lanes or to
charge certain companies more to have
their content delivered at speed the
line from Comcast and others has been
super clear from the beginning which is
be against net neutrality with us
because we would never do all these bad
things that we would be allowed to do if
net neutrality were repealed and in fact
there's a quote from David Cohen who's a
Comcast senior executive VP back in May
of 2014 he said quote to be clear
comcast has never offered paid
prioritization we are not offering it
today and we're not considering entering
into any paid prioritization creating
fast lanes with content owners that
promise is now gone from Comcast website
and in fact it went away a couple of
months ago when they started very
aggressively pushing the new Ajit PI
Trump FCC to repeal net neutrality they
saw an opening once Donald Trump became
president and put a GPI in the FCC and
they quietly removed that promise from
their website and instead now they are
promising number one they won't
discriminate against lawful content
which is meaningless right what does it
mean you what you won't discriminate
against lawful content that just means
that you're not going to discriminate
against content that has not yet been
found to be illegal by a court of law
it's a distraction act actually from net
neutrality and they are now promising
not to impose anti-competitive paid
prioritization that is a keyword because
who decides whether the paid
prioritization is anti-competitive
comcast decides as soon as net
neutrality is repealed Comcast can say
hey we offer internet fast lanes but not
anti-competitive ones for example if
Comcast decides to charge Netflix way
more money to be delivered at speed to
consumers
they might say listen it's not
anti-competitive because Netflix has a
lot of money it's not an undue burden on
to them which of course ignores the
reality that if that's done to Netflix
more than likely they would pass that
cost along to you and me all of the
Netflix subscribers and the other
realization that we all need to come to
is that it doesn't matter what companies
like Comcast said before or even what
they say now there's no law that says
they can't change their plan right which
is why we need to be concerned only with
what would they be allowed to do this is
a regular thing in contract law
employment contract all sorts of
contracts lawyers start talking to each
other and they're talking mostly about
actions that neither of the parties to
the contract would ever take
deliberately anyway but the problem is
what would a contract allow someone to
do that is the liability and that is why
we shouldn't worry at all and by worried
I mean pay attention to what Comcast
says they would or wouldn't do because
what we need to be concerned with is
what would they be allowed to do and I
wouldn't be surprised if Comcast has
their new pricing models ready to go
already that include different tiers of
internet access or whatever the case may
be you know these companies have been
planning for what seems to be an
inevitable repeal of net neutrality I
hope I'm wrong about that but I think
I'm right sadly and you need to remember
that fast lanes are only fast relative
to slow lanes and unless you slow
something down there's no need to pay to
speed it up and that's what we all need
to remember when we think about the
entire concept of internet fast lanes
and slow lanes this is a real concern
this is a crisis situation and I don't
want to understate that in any way send
me your thoughts about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
twitter at david pakman show the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is kenneth Cusick kenneth Cusick thank
you so much for being a david pakman
show member we are truly independent
audience supported media two best ways
to support number one do what kenneth
did go to david pakman.com slash
membership and sign up number two
goto patreon.com slash david pakman show
and make a pledge of as little as a
dollar a month any amount is welcome and
lastly david pakman.com slash
cryptocurrency to contribute via bitcoin
aetherium or litecoin thanks to
everybody who has already done that you
can tell a lot about a presidential
administration from who they hire but
you can also tell a lot about an
administration from who quits and now
Donald Trump's White House ethics lawyer
has quit which is hugely shocking
because who could have possibly imagined
that Donald Trump even had an ethics
lawyer and was still doing all the
things that he's been doing but he did
his name was his name still is but he's
no longer the ethics lawyer James
Schultz James Schultz has resigned done
dealing with Donald Trump's ethical and
financial disclosure issues he's moving
to the I guess less stressful job of
private law practice I believe in
Philadelphia is where he previously
worked he says that it has nothing to do
with the permanent insanity of the Trump
administration I don't personally
believe that I don't know of a rational
person who would leave a job that's
going great in the White House after
just ten months or so although Schultz
has been quoted as saying oh it's
completely typical for people to stay in
these positions 12 to 18 months that may
be true we're only ten months into this
administration and it's it's gonna have
to be the Republican National Committee
or Fox News or some Republican lobbying
firm they'd better get this guy with
some huge bogus salary ASAP so that he
doesn't feel inclined to come clean
about the atrocities he witnessed while
representing Donald Trump's ethics in
the White House and I mostly get the
picture that he just wasn't getting paid
enough to deal with this degree of
insanity his salary I believe was a
hundred and forty thousand dollars and
compared to what he could likely be
making in private law practice at
relatively less stress probably wasn't
making it worth it to stay in this
position seriously though why would
Donald Trump need an ethics lawyer his
ethics or his personal philosophy as
I've said before is greed and personal
self enrichment period there really
aren't other considerations and the idea
of an ethics lawyer saying to Trump mr.
president
what you're proposing to do could really
appear to be a conflict of interest
because of XYZ that just doesn't even
rate with Trump in my mind I imagine
Trump looking kind of like your dog
looks when it hears your voice come out
of the answering machine yeah we're just
kind of look what at what are you what
are you saying a conflict of interest I
don't even understand why that matters
well that reminds me when the cat's away
the mice will play
yes so now I'm worried that people in
the White House are gonna start doing
all sorts of unethical things yeah if
you thought Trump was unethical with a
White House Ethics lawyer following him
around proverbially or literally then
just wait until they I don't expect this
position to be filled super soon I don't
know that lawyers are necessarily super
eager to become Trump's ethics advisors
okay their time on this one they'll take
it like with many others this is one
that they're gonna take their time on
being Trump's White House ethics lawyer
is kind of like working in the gender
non-discrimination Department of Fox
News or something like that it's a
pointless job and I imagine that it's
also a futile job anyway he's gone James
Schultz is gone never knew the guy low
paid intern never gave us any advice
worth taking and he's now at a failing
fake news law firm of some kind and
we're just gonna focus on making America
great again
nobody knows who this guy even was but
he's gone and we'll never hear from him
again unless he decides to show up on
Fox News or CNN and start telling us
airing some of the dirty laundry of
Donald Trump I can't believe we're doing
this
but we have to remember the ax
Hollywood grabbed him by the
you-know-what tapes of Donald Trump that
set off that firestorm the recording
ended up getting Billy Bush fired from
television but it didn't stop Donald
Trump from becoming president of the
United States which is weird and you'll
remember that Trump admitted that it was
him on the tapes right Trump admitted it
was him he apologized for what he
described as locker room talk on the
tape and generally you don't apologize
for something you never did now Donald
Trump is questioning whether the tapes
are actually authentic or whether
they've been doctored we learned over
the Thanksgiving holiday that earlier
this year Donald Trump told a u.s.
senator that the Access Hollywood tapes
might not be authentic he recently
repeated the exact same claim to an
advisor and Access Hollywood
understandably had to respond and say no
no that the tape is completely real they
said on a recent broadcast let us make
this perfectly clear the tape is very
real remember his excuse at the time was
locker room talk he said every one of
those words I want to remind you again
Trump already admitted that it's his
voice on the tapes and apologized for
what he said how do you go from
apologizing for it to say there was
never anything real to apologize for in
the first place
here's just a little bit of that apology
that Donald Trump issued I've said and
done things I regret
and the words released today on this
more than a decade old video are one of
them right anyone who knows me knows
these words don't reflect Who I am I
said it I was wrong and I apologize wow
I've traveled the country talking about
change for America that's pretty
definitive I said it I was wrong and I
apologize that apology was over
something fake that never happened now
there are a couple reasons why Trump
might do this the easiest and the
simplest is he's completely narcissistic
and thinks that maybe it's been long
enough that somebody might start to
believe him that hey the tapes were
doctored the second option is that it's
part of this four dimensional
that Trump plays meant to distract from
something else or create media mayhem
who knows that's another possibility I
would question whether Trump even can
play regular chess but never mind 4d
chess a third option which is similar to
the 4d chess option but but not quite as
refined is that Trump has learned that
there could be even worse stuff coming
out at some point in the future and that
he's laying the groundwork to question
the authenticity of all of it and I
don't know what those recordings might
be we did hear before the election about
Tom Arnold said he had some recordings
related to the apprentice when Donald
Trump was on the apprentice and that
supposedly the stuff he did behind the
scenes that The Apprentice blows out of
the water the Access Hollywood tapes we
never heard more about that it's a
possibility that Trump is laying the
groundwork and kind of preemptively
playing defense for when those comes out
those come out and that really gets us
to the actual tragedy in this which is
and it pains me to say this it really
does some of Trump supporters are gonna
eat this up and believe it 110 percent
there is a group of Trump supporters
that has such cognitive dissonance when
it comes to Trump the hero versus Trump
the serial sexual assault er that they
will hear Donald Trump question the
authenticity of a tape that he's now not
only acknowledged the truth of but also
apologized for and they will start to
repeat it and say hey Trump said it the
tape is fake and those are the people
Pat that will never abandon the guy and
we need to forget about them when we
think about winning elections in the
future well I mean how many times has
Trump contradicted himself and how many
times has he peddled conspiracy theories
and it's just putting those two things
together
absolutely so that is the most
disturbing part of it that even though
it is so transparent so pathetically
bogus what Donald Trump is saying here
that the tapes might not be authentic it
has always worked it has always worked
for Trump and it will continue to work
for Donald Trump and that's why we need
to go around trumpets to win elections
in the United States special elections
in 2017 midterms in 2018 and the general
election
in 2020 discuss this with us on our
reddit discussion forum many of you are
nearly 5000 of you now on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t the david pakman show
at david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show it's great to be
joined today by neil howe who is an
author demographer managing director of
demography at hedge eye risk management
and the man who coined the term
millennial you may also recognize his
last name from Strauss how generational
theory and we'll talk about how that
connects to some modern political
happenings as well
neil it's so great to have you on i
appreciate you taking the time to talk
to me today thank you it's it's
wonderful to be here so let's talk a
little bit about Strauss how
generational theory for people who may
be uninitiated in that generally
speaking when did you start researching
that and how did you develop that theory
we started working on this in the late
1980s we did a very large book project
really retelling all of American history
from the 17th century on our from the
viewpoint of separate kind of collective
generational biographies and that book
was published in in 1991 it was called
generations the history of America's
future we did another book on Generation
X and then in 1997 we did a book called
the fourth turning which revisits
generational theory but looks at it a
little bit more explicitly in terms of
social and political and cultural cycles
generated by this this sort of you know
collective biographical change and that
that is probably the book that people
you know remember most in terms of
predictions we made about where America
is going and for the
matter much of the world and it's based
on the idea of for roughly 20 years
stages that recur in a sort of cyclical
way can you talk to us a little bit
about the four stages yes they're there
for different kinds of generations we
call them archetypes and you know some
like like boomers I think all Americans
today familiar with them are born right
after crises indulgently raised and they
come of age with the Great Awakenings of
American history these great kind of
cataclysmic and and often somewhat
somewhat violent or acrimonious breaks
in our culture and values and then there
are other types of generations like what
we call the hero archetype which is you
know protectively raised right after an
awakening and typically comes of age
during the great crises of our history
but but it's interesting that American
history has these regular rhythms of
kind of times when we make the inner
world and remake the outer world the
great political and civic crises of our
history have all been separated by about
the length of a long human life about 80
or 90 years and roughly in between
halfway in between we have the great
kind of cultural upheavals the remaking
of our inner world the Great Awakenings
you know we used to even name number
them you know first Great Awakening
Second Great Awakening third and so on
and and that gives rise to a alternating
series of kind of seasons of history
first turning when institutions are
strong individualism as weak society
feels a great sense of you know
collective momentum toward the future
and then the second turnings are the
Great Awakenings when people tire of all
the social discipline and the conformity
and try to refine themselves these are
the great individualizing periods of our
history the third turning when
institutions is discredited in
individualism as flourishing government
and others we enjoy periods of weak
government weak regulation these are
these are the great periods of sort of
free agency in American history often
periods a very high immigration and then
the this concludes with that kind of a
winter season if you will of of crisis
of outer world change this is when we
kind of tear down and rebuild the realm
of politics economy and Empire and these
are the these are often periods of total
war in American history how far back
does this four cycle four stage cycle
fit into American history well in
actually in the in the fourth journey we
take it all the way back to the late
Middle Ages with sort of anglo-american
history in generations we really started
with sort of the the Armada crisis which
came right before they you know the the
epic confrontation between England and
Spain which happened just before the
Puritan generation was born who actually
you know constituted the great migration
to New England in the 1630s
but ever since then and you know we've
had we've had the the probably the first
great global war in Western history was
the word Spanish Succession and the
Glorious Revolution in England which
certainly involved the colonies lifetime
after that we had the American
Revolution and lifetime after that we
had the civil war we had World War two
and and and in the and the Great
Depression and and now here we are
so we'll get to Stephen Bannen in a bit
but before that I'd be curious to hear
from you you depending on what you read
you see that there are some who tend to
be more social conservatives who
evaluate your theory and say oh that
means we might be getting close to sort
of getting back to the social
conservatism of the 40s and 50s and then
you also see some liberals who will
interpret your theory and say oh we
might be getting ready to move away from
the sort of Reagan Bush deregulation and
get back into something that will appeal
more to social progressives where do you
assess that we are right now I assess
that that you could interpret it either
way because in fact these these fourth
turnings tend to be accompanied by by a
kind of a
traditionalism or classicism or if you
want to define a conservatism the
culture but definitely toward a movement
it left or in the populist or
authoritarian direction in the economy
so you know depending on your politics
you could be on the left or on the right
and either look favorably on this or or
not forth turnings tend to redefine what
we mean by left and right and I think
part of that redefinition is already
going on today particularly since the
last election well to talk about that a
little bit I mean I guess to get us into
the entire Steve Bannon thing for people
who don't know Steve ban and I guess is
a sort of a scholar or student of your
theory although not not a personal
student of yours as I'm sure you'll tell
us how did you first come to know that
Straus how generational theory was of
interest to Stephen Bennett I I don't
know it goes back many years I think he
Proust contacted us maybe
eight or nine or 10 years ago I didn't
know who he was so I don't think I ever
got back to him it was but he was a it
was a film director in LA and I think
what people don't realize is that since
his Goldman's sac days he's goldman
sachs days he's really been involved in
entertainment in the media i mean that's
really what interests him a direction in
the pop culture he's not primarily
oriented around political principle or
religion he has a he has he has a flair
or a an instinct for where the culture
is going and he particularly as its
interpreted through entertainment video
games media and so forth
but anyway he later on did a documentary
called generation zero which I agreed to
participate in a bit I thought it was an
interesting thesis and and and he's done
a fair amount of directing since then
and I've I've you know met with him a
number of times on that is your sense
that the way in which his interpretation
of your theory as it applies to thinking
about how he advised the Trump camp
is it true in some way to walk to how
you develop this do you see it as a
departure or perversion or
misinterpretation of your theory I mean
what are your thoughts now that we know
that this was so has so informed how he
has sort of entered politics over the
last years
it's definitely sensationalization or
popularization of what we did there's no
question about that but but it's
interesting that his loyalty as
undoubtedly you know since you've been
following him is not really to the Trump
administration and he said that several
times he doesn't really care where Trump
is going he he is dedicated to the
formation of this new populist movement
this populist party if the GOP is a good
vehicle for that then fine he thinks
that's you know a good bet for him now
but if it isn't he'll find some other
way to do it so I guess I guess what I
mean to say about that is he's not
looking at this as a tool to revitalize
the GOP I don't really honestly don't
think he cares too much about what
happens to the Republican Party well
aside from viewing it as a tool I mean
can it even really be a tool in the
sense that if there are these roughly
four 20 year periods that lead to a
single 80 year cycle if that is some
sort of natural place that society
settles in Kent can you really do
anything about that in other words would
knowledge of that really allow you to
change the course of that or do you
believe that that's just the natural
course of things regardless of people's
awareness of it or not
well it's interesting if you if you view
history as being in some respects or in
some aspects of its cyclical and and by
the way this was the ancient belief you
know before the rise of of monotheistic
religion and so on all traditional
societies all pre-modern societies saw
time is basically cyclical and you
didn't try to change it you tried to
perform well within it and I think that
actually gives you a good guide as to as
to as I better look back on history it's
not so much that you can
boy the turnings you can't suddenly try
to imagine that The Awakening isn't
going to happen or that a fourth turning
mood will not happen I think then what
you focus on in terms of your own
choices how do you make this end well
right how does every actor play their
roles well so that it ends most happily
and productively and fruitfully for all
involved as opposed to being a truly
horrible and destructive Cataclysm which
all of us want to avoid what would you
see today as sort of a key
distinguishing a key distinguisher
between the Millennial and following
generation and the older generations
within the sort of a political economy I
guess I would say in the way that it
would impact elections is there some key
difference other than just age and
interests for example or how they choose
to spend their money the simple stuff
that we read articles about all the time
that you think really distinguishes the
younger generations from the older
generations alive today well one of the
things we see with Millennials and by
the way this is not just here in the
United States this is in Britain this is
in Europe and this is in East Asia you
see this is an attraction to sort of one
size fits all solutions kind of populist
/ authoritarian solutions which remake
institutions which work well for their
future it's interesting today in in in
Southeast Asia for example you see the
young hugely supporting these new
charismatic authoritarian populist
leaders like Narendra Modi and India Xi
Jinping in China Shinzo Abe a and in
Britain and in in Japan and Rodrigo
Duterte in the Philippines all of these
leaders were disproportionately favored
by young people I mean is he young
Filipinos have voted in to tear take
young young Chinese now are usually
supportive of Xi Jinping they're all
trying to get into the Communist Party
where it's 20 years ago they weren't you
see that too and all of these leaders by
the way are trying to orient their new
definition of nationalism around the
kind of the main cultural social
religious mainstream of their country
you look at Europe right now with the
new identity rien movement you know
we've gone from identity politics in the
60s to identitarian ISM in in in in in
that in 2010's and I think that's a
telling shift and we see in in America
where Millennials were hugely in favor
of you know on the here and you here you
see it on the left which was Bernie
Sanders as well as in you know that
Jeremy Corbyn in the UK you've got an
absolutely epic shift toward young
voters when he said I think we should
make tuition free and invest hugely in
infrastructure here's the problem is
that Millennials around the world
they're looking particularly in liberal
democracies they are seeing older
individualistic leaders like boomers
fail at the basic tasks of governance
they have no focus on the future they're
not even discussing much less coming to
terms with any issue that affects their
you know their long-term prospects
another interesting figment of this or
another outgrowth of this and if you
look at p.m. Millennials around the
world what they think of China right now
older people when you ask them there's a
Pew study that really documents this
well older people think well China they
really don't approve of it it's an
authoritarian regime they they crush
dissidents and so on we think that's bad
the Millennials around the world thinks
China's pretty neat I mean they invest
you know forty percent of the national
income in the future they're building
250 mile an hour bullet trains you know
they they make the trains run on time
and they you know it's kind of that's
because society that works so here's
what I see and people sometimes ask me
how do you know that a society is moving
from a you know post-war mood to a
pre-war mood right and that's kind of
hard to tell before there's another war
or before another Christ Civic crisis of
some kind I would say a good clue is to
the respective attitudes of young and
old adult institutional Authority and
social order
in a post-war era it's the old people
who actually just went through the Civic
crisis who are supportive of civic order
and it's the young people who resent it
who
you know rebel against it and so forth
and of course that's what we had earlier
in the post you know world war ii era
you know you're going to a pre-war era
when the older people are the you know
great defenders of libertarianism and
individualism and everyone's you know
right to due process and sort of
basically sealing off their rights or
their entitlements to whatever wealth
and power older people are enjoying and
it's the younger people who become more
in favor of government strong government
that actually works get things done and
actually you know shifts things more in
their direction that is to say toward
the future and I think that's where we
beginning to see around much of the
world today it's manifesting itself on
the left or on the right depending on
which country you look at we've been
speaking with Neil how he is an author
demographer managing director of
demography at hedge eye risk management
Neil thanks so much for talking to me
today you're welcome
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so we're back from Thanksgiving and
whether you did the Black Friday
shopping thing or you did the Black
Friday don't buy anything thing that's
what I did I actually have something for
you starting today that I think you're
really going to like and it's not
something you're going to throw out
after two days it's something you will
actually use for an entire year the year
of 2018 we have done David Pakman show
calendars for years we did a 2015
calendar we did a 2016 calendar we did a
2017 calendar each time with greater and
greater success and a few weeks ago I
mentioned I don't really have plans to
do one for 2018 things have been so
hectic we've been dealing with YouTube D
monetization we lost our Amazon
affiliate link I started the patreon a
fundraiser I'm teaching at Boston
College it's just been way too hectic to
do a calendar haven't even had time to
think about it but I received a bunch of
emails from people saying David when
will the 2018 calendars be available I
really want a 2018 calendar and I can
tell you that thanks to the great work
of three david pakman show viewers Dan
Burke Corey top kiss and Anthony Pat
Ramallah
who has helped with the calendar by the
way since the first year we did at the
2015 calendar the 2018 David Pakman show
calendar is now available this is the
cover which we're showing you and on the
cover you see cartoon if occations of me
Donald Trump Steve Bannon Kelly Anne
Conway and Vladimir Putin and it is all
original artwork and it is such I
actually believe this may be the best
calendar yet because over time we get a
better and better sense of what makes a
good calendar and there's a couple of
options for getting it all of them are
available at david pakman.com slash
calendar 18 now let me just restate
because sometimes we have issues with
this it's david pakman.com slash
calendar 1 h not Calendar 2018 okay
david pakman.com slash calendar 18
couple of options and you'll see them on
the website david pakman.com slash
calendar 18 number one you can get the
calendar with a yearly membership for
free ok it's got to be a yearly
membership and you have to use the link
at david pakman.com slash calendar 818
if you use that option if you get the
calendar for free with a membership it
comes autographed automatically for free
now if you just want the calendar
there's also a link to that at david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 you can get
just the calendar either autographed for
a little bit more it's a fundraiser
after all come on play along or not
autographed and free shipping within the
United States International shipping is
extra now a common question is if you
already have a membership what do you do
well you can decide if you've just
created a yearly membership you might
say oh I'll just get the calendar alone
and there's a Members Only discount for
the calendar which we'll talk about on
the bonus show and you can decide to go
about it that way or if you're like on a
monthly membership or your yearly
membership may be is almost over you can
cancel your existing membership restart
your membership and get the calendar for
free the art is really really great Dan
Burke did his great original cartoons we
have one example that we're showing our
television audience these are completely
original some of them involve David
Pakman as a character this particular
strip I've grown a big beard and there's
a whole storyline behind that it's
really really good stuff
Corey top kiss also did some really
great art including one piece that sort
of Andy Warhol esque which was then
modified by Anthony Pett ramallah edited
and and built upon and it's a really
really funny and good calendar so check
it out david pakman.com slash calendar
18 a real conversation starter I assure
you if you put this thing up on your
fridge if you have people who go to your
house sometimes or inside your office or
your cubicle people write to me and they
say I have a lot of conservative people
that work with me and they walk by my
cubicle and they see my camp calendar
and it looks interesting so they get
closer and they start looking at it and
I just see their faces drop because of
all the liberal propaganda on the
calendar yeah I mean the holidays are
coming up to what a better gift then to
give your supporting family members
these make perfect gifts actually for
Trump supporting family members and and
really for anybody it's a great gift so
please check it out david pakman
calm / calendar 18 the audience is
bigger than ever this year then it's
been in the past so so speaking merely
mathematically we should be able to sell
more calendars than ever before other
big news for the David Pakman show
I love having positive news lately
because 2017 has had a lot of really
really bad news
the big news is that the david pakman
show podcast is now on spotify if you go
to spotify either mobile or desktop and
search for the david pakman show you
will find the david pakman show podcasts
really big deal Spotify was initially
mostly just music it has grown to
include podcasts it is becoming a major
podcast platform and not everybody can
just put their podcast on Spotify we
were actually invited to put the David
Pakman show on Spotify and we are now on
iTunes I Heart Radio stitcher and
Spotify and you can follow us there
really really great stuff so I'm excited
about this I actually I love it when we
get on a platform I use and I use
Spotify all the time when I'm at the gym
I'm listening to music and podcasts on
Spotify and very very exciting so that's
available and also as I mentioned
yesterday steam it okay you can support
the show merely by upvoting our content
and you can make some money yourselves
by going to steam it calm that's ste MIT
dot-com create an account takes a couple
days for it to be verified but don't get
put off by that and then follow us
steam it comm slash at David Pakman at
sign David Pakman and just buy up voting
our content you will be supporting the
work we do so really good stuff it's
good to have good news because between D
monetization on YouTube and the the
destruction as I call it the elimination
of our Amazon affiliate link and all of
this different stuff it's nice to have
some wins yeah towards the end of the
year we like to keep it light you know
at the Jenga segment yeah male this is
great news as well yes and by the way
Pat has already committed to buying a
hundred and fifty thousand david pakman
show calendars we are not going to be
including those numbers towards the goal
because we it's great that you're
picking up
these calendars but really the idea is
for the audience to buy as many as
possible just like them all for myself I
know it will listen we can the great
thing is we can get as many calendars as
we need because we have a print supply
shop that has unlimited resources so if
everybody wants a calendar they can get
it and that's another thing I mentioned
david pakman.com slash calendar 1:8
to get the 2018 calendar okay let's go
to your voicemails voicemail number is
two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day many of you do call at
very unusual times of day and that's
okay we heard from the eggman recently
and the Eggman is pointing out that he
believes what anthony weiner was found
guilty of is not nearly as bad as what
alabama republican senate candidate Roy
Moore is accused of take a listen to
what the Eggman said hi Dave I think
what Roy Moore is accused of doing is so
much worse than what Anthony Weiner has
been convicted of doing I don't like all
these false equivalence well what about
Clinton what about what about but if
they want to go that route what about
Weiner okay forget it
Roy Moore is fine he can do that but let
Weiner out and put him back in
governments guy I want to pull Weiner
off the farm team and bring him back out
because he's nothing compared to this
scumbag Roy Moore that's all yeah we're
against the ranking of sexual assault
and sex crimes but that being said I
think you can still draw similarities
and differences between different
incidents and I tend to agree with what
the eggman says I've never defended
Anthony Weiner's actions and I don't I
just don't think they're as bad as what
Roy Moore is accused of yeah I mean I
don't think the Anthony Weiner stuff
would be a big deal had he not sent
images of himself underage girl no doubt
about it
no question about it so egg man thank
you very much for calling in and you can
see what he's thinking about these days
up there in upstate rural upstate New
York
he also said pull Weiner he's at the
yeah he wants to see Weiner polled and
that's fine that's fine nobody'll on the
bonus show today why the massacre of
Muslims in the site in the Sinai was too
extra
even for al-qaeda what does that even
mean we'll also talk about a mysterious
object that has been confirmed to be
from another solar system but it's not a
UFO it's just an object from another
solar system we'll talk about that on
the bonus show and are we heading
towards YouTube ad pocalypse 2.0 there
is a new ad pocalypse candle over videos
sexualizing little kids on YouTube how
are we dealing with this again this
story and others on the bonus show today
get accessed by going to david
pakman.com slash membership and signing
up or by becoming a $5 a month patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
we'll speak to you them
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you